the show me something draft peter king i
i don't see a trivia question for today
so i am going to go ahead and give you
the first pick who needs to show you
something the most this weekend
uh the
entity that needs to show me the most
this weekend is the detroit lions
uh especially on defense
they have allowed four consecutive games
where they are in the last four games
they have blown
double-digit leads and they've lost them
all
uh matt patricia obviously on an 11-game
losing streak
playing at the cardinals it's going to
be a very tough game but there's a
reason why you spent all this money to
build a great defense there's a reason
for it we haven't seen it yet
but that defense needs to start showing
up and that's who i want to see
something from on sunday
yeah you're right and i i i agree with
you i just don't think there's anything
to see nothing to see here they can't
show us anything because the cupboard's
bare i'm gonna go
up to a team that we talked about
earlier in detail the seattle seahawks
dallas cowboys game mike mccarthy the
strategy there for keeping russell
wilson off the field look mccarthy's had
a rough go of it so far he needs to to
not make
a big mistake this week he's he's made
multiple big mistakes so far
in his time as cowboys head coach going
forward on fourth and three throwing the
ball short of the sticks although the
execution's not on him the preparation
for the execution's on him calling that
play is ultimately on him and then last
week two fake punts two very ill-advised
fake punts and then the decision to go
for two when down nine which i'm i'm
sorry i i get the analytics when you're
up or when you're down 14 and you score
a touchdown go for two that makes sense
when you're up one you score a touchdown
go for two make it a two score game i
get a lot of it i don't get going for
two when you're down nine points and
making it a still a two score game if
you fail so they won that game despite
some of his decisions he needs to make
some decisions that make the difference
this week for the cowboys against a team
like the seahawks peter
i agree with you
and although i'm very happy to see
mccarthy embrace analytics
after his career in green bay when
you i i
you cannot
go for two when you're
down nine points
it doesn't make any sense
my next one mike jerick mckinnon show me
something all right and again this is a
little bit harder very good this is a
little bit harsh
but in 2017
kyle shanahan watching tape after that
season fell in love with mckinnon you
know who knows if all went well and they
signed him maybe he becomes what clinton
portis was for kyle's father okay and so
he comes in 2018 get gets hurt season is
ruined
2019 comes back gets hurt sees in his
room two lost years
and there's the very real possibility
that he never becomes anything for this
team and now all of a sudden rain
mustard hurt
and
right now in a game
with that the 49ers really have to have
at the meadowlands on sunday in a bit of
a landmine game because it looks like
nick mullins is going to be the
quarterback in this game it's a tough
game to win
there needs to be
25 touches
for jarrick mckinnon and he needs to be
the guy who carries the san francisco
49ers in a game that they absolutely
have to have
yeah no mostar no coleman and now
mckinnon has the chance to become what
they expect him to be when they gave him
that huge contract it was stunning how
much they paid him in early 2018. i'm
gonna go with another guy we talked
about earlier because i firmly believe
this is the chance for derek carr to
show everyone something to finally get
to the point where you know he's he said
i'm sick of the disrespect he said it
over and over again to the point where
people started to push back saying
go out and play better then if you're if
you're sick of the talk if you're sick
of being disrespected the one way to win
respect is to go to new england and win
go there and win the game play like
russell wilson did against the patriots
on sunday night this is your opportunity
to show us all and to shut us all up you
want it go get it and if you don't get
it quit complaining about the people who
point out that there is a gap between
you and the best quarterbacks in the nfl
peter
i couldn't agree more on that derek carr
can solidify
some gruden insurance with a win
my third one mike show me something is
josh allen he's had a tremendous start
to his season
uh but now he's got a face
right in his face
the best defensive player in football
for 65 snaps on sunday in buffalo he
will not have the crowd to be on his
side uh and he basically has got to
make he's got to ensure
that what he does with his offense
is put him in position to not turn the
ball over against a a really good
forceful defense it isn't only aaron
donald but obviously it's jalen ramsey
and so to me
you know josh allen has had a very good
start to his season had a great game in
miami last weekend
but this
it's a two-and-oh team rams come in
aaron donald best player in football
best defensive player in football
and right now it's got to be a time
where josh allen says i cannot let aaron
donald ruin this game
yeah you're absolutely right this is a
huge test for josh allen and also he
needs to show us that he is at least
partially aware of the importance of
keeping himself in one piece that run
that he had last week you know i made
the comment earlier in the week that the
bills have been waiting for the next jim
kelly and their next thurman thomas they
got it in the same guy he pla i mean he
he runs with a reckless abandon that
really is reckless and is going to get
him injured if he doesn't stop and if he
comes up against aaron donald my advice
is take a slide take a seat don't let
aaron donald hit you or you may not get
up right next one for me and and i hate
to say this because i'm a huge desean
watson fan
but you get the giant contract just a
few days before week one
lose to the chiefs
lose last weekend get blown off the
field kind of against the ravens you
know deshaun watson is in this group of
young up-and-coming quarterbacks
and he's the only one of them that's
owen two
and and i know to a certain extent they
got screwed by the schedule i don't know
who they upset at 345 park avenue but to
come out of the gates with chiefs ravens
and now at pittsburgh but but this is
the chance to remind everyone that
desean watson is still one of the best
few quarterbacks in the nfl the steelers
have not been dominant their defense is
made is made he plays at key moments he
could have lost well he's played the two
best teams in football so far so i don't
give him i i don't i don't kill him
for this
but the one thing that i would say about
desean watson is there are times as a
quarterback as the guy who's the nerve
center of your team
there's there are times when you say i
gotta win this game on my own it's like
lebron james at the end of a game
uh he wants the ball in his hands
deshawn watson has got to want the ball
in his hands and if his receivers aren't
open he's got to take the game into his
own hands and run it 15 times you don't
want to make a living doing that but
this week i'd say is about as close to a
must win as they have because they're
not going to be able to afford um to
lose very many more games and continue
that winning streak atop the division
yeah the titans are likely going to be
3-0 the colts are likely going to be
two-in-one you lose this one and fall to
0-3 you got a major problem and they're
still working through that adjustment
from
having deandre hopkins to not having
deandre hopkins and it really has to
chafe deshaun watson to see how well
hopkins is doing with the cardinals but
the texans at some level want him to
grow beyond having one guy that he
throws to all the time they want him to
spread the ball around they want him to
be in charge of the offense not deandre
hopkins but it's just unfortunate that
it's gone so well for hopkins and so
poorly so far for the texans peter
they just weren't going to pay de'andre
hopkins 20 22 million dollars a year
they just weren't going to do that they
thought he was a very slightly declining
player he obviously isn't and i think
you look at deandre hopkins now he's in
the perfect position
absolutely unequivocally perfect that's
why i think arizona goes to 3-0 this
weekend